so uh we obviously bombed syria which is
that's
which is awesome i think it's amazing
and um
let's uh let's actually play
some of the uh some of the things here
for uh one of the former state
department officials
who is defending the air strike because
i kind of want to see
what it was here we go consulting is
this david at a time when
the overweening threat to the country
clearly is china by every measurement
possible
we're energy independent we don't need
to focus on the middle east
and yet we're still wasting the time of
the us military the attention of our
unbelievably british looking
mum he's not though he's actually not
he's
he just has one of those like yeah
british faces
yeah tanks the public's precious
attention span
on the middle east and syria tell me why
this is wise
well let me give you some perspective uh
first of all president
trump did and i expected to hear from
that board let me give you some
perspective
i mean that's like i was i was
literally waiting to hear hello tucker
and thanks for having me today
my name is tom yeah in april 2017. he
did another
another one in april 2018 and another
december
2019. and for all three
they were justified and proportional i
spoke about them i wrote about them i
supported them
to your credit you were against all of
them so we've both been
consistent but we have a divide here
it's really not yeah no i wasn't happy
let me clear here i wasn't happy when
trump did it either
so don't think that i was not about
syria policy and the details of syria
what's happening in syria and iraq
it's really about what should america's
role in the world be
i happen to think that we can continue
to project
power abroad and that we have to have
our diplomats
but why does projecting power always
involve killing a bunch of people
yeah like i'm pretty sure people know at
this point that we
can kill them how many nukes do we have
we have enough to end the world 30 times
over
that's pretty powerful we don't need to
be [ __ ] bombing weddings to prove uh
hey you see that [ __ ] wedding look
how powerful we are hey uh
mr president hear me out on this could
you do it
could you just do it launch them all
just launch them all let's just go
is this my ice cream button no joe
there's no ice cream button
uh oh this is my ice cream bun
not the because you get with the ice
cream
joe you just nuked beijing that's and
soldiers
stations just killed our bosses joe you
just killed our bosses in beijing
and then all of a sudden you see them go
oh my god we're free
you just nuked the chinese oh my god we
are so fired
in order to do that and when they get
attacked as they did on february 15th
in northern iraq by shia militias it's
appropriate for us to respond
as biden did just as trump did in
december 2019.
i'm leaving aside and i'll i'll even
gloss over your claim that it was
justified of course the state department
lied
about the pretext for the first missile
strike but leaving is the state
department
ever lied literally
every benghazi okay one thing you can't
name like
another thing the state department ever
lied about war on terror
two things but if you name a third thing
maybe i'll be on your side
aside china is humiliating the united
states globally it is colonizing
the entire continent of africa and the
caribbean right at our shores
it is humiliating american diplomats by
giving them unnecessary
rectal swabs either did you see that so
there was american diplomats in china
and china convinced them that the only
way
the only test they would accept for a
covet test was a rectal swab and they
gave rep
rectal swabs to american diplomats
that's a true fact it's a real thing you
can look it up for yourself i mean this
is not something that people are making
up
this is real they're sticking q-tips up
our diplomats [ __ ]
china's projecting power without bombing
us
it is
to the entire globe and we do nothing
when a syrian militia lobs rockets into
iraq
we pounce this is a question of focus
you can't fix every problem why aren't
we focusing on the real problem why are
we wasting time in the middle east
well i happen to think we can walk and
chew gum at the same time so yeah but in
this case we're walking and bombing
weddings
it's a little different than chewing gum
yeah
we can deal with the middle east a
little bit different than speaking
softly and carrying a big stick yeah
it's just sodomizing everyone in the
middle east with the stick
yeah and we can also deal with china
and i do agree with you that china is
really our biggest rival
especially going forward but right now
china isn't supporting groups that are
directly firing rockets at our personnel
so we have to respond no
they're just undermining us and
literally every
other [ __ ] form they can cyber
attacks
economic warfare uh undermining us
undermining our trade uh buying off our
politicians
spying on us copyrights but but
hey at least they're not firing at least
they're not throwing rocks at israeli
tanks bro
because that would be [ __ ] up
and you know what's great too is he goes
well you know because they're firing
rockets at us yes
in their own backyard correct it's not
look hey if some syrians decided to
start
firing off stinger missiles in the
middle of [ __ ] new york city i'd go
hey you know what
[ __ ] them get those sons of [ __ ] i'm
with you but
they're it's this is the equivalent of
like when you think about
uh like the castle doctrine and stand
your ground and stuff right like
i am never going to go after somebody
who shoots somebody in their own
property like somebody gets on your
property there's some kind of
situation i don't know about and uh
there's a fight
uh and somebody ends up shot if you're
the guy who owns the property i'm not
maybe the other guy shouldn't have been
there that's just my philosophy about it
to that in syria to protect our
personnel we also should be doing things
to prepare for a potential battle for
china
in the future in the places like you
mentioned in africa where it truly
wants to expand and where we can't have
a potential fight with china
we've already lost that fight should
have been a long time ago
we've already [ __ ] lost
wants to put its vision of government a
kleptocracy
in place and we have to fight them not
just not just with our economy not just
uh with our usaid and not just with
foreign investment
but also also with an ideology of
democracy and freedom
which is a ah see mike uh let me
translate for you
the haters because of our freedom uh i
just translated for you wherever i heard
this one before
hmm that sound that one sounds familiar
so cha
so so let me get this straight china is
ruining our country way worse than
anything the middle east could possibly
do
but china gets a slap on the wrist and
the middle east gets [ __ ] bombed
i see makes sense countering who gets
who gets it the middle east china ocean
sure
theology to the one that china wants to
put in place
across the world we're supine or servile
our generals retire and serve china our
largest corporations profit from china
our political class refuses to criticize
china so
nothing you're saying has actually
happened are going to happen as we both
know but let me just back up
fair enough talk i love i love rudolph
really just blows somebody off
you know again that's great it's fine
it's not going to happen anyway there's
there's literally
nothing that shows even even a little
bit that those things are gonna happen
to the middle east because it's it's the
region in question tonight
why do we have troops in iraq we haven't
improved iraq we haven't improved the
united states by keeping there why do we
think
this will be different from every other
middle eastern country we've been
engaged in
all of which wind up worse we wind up
poor americans wind up dead
are those poppy fields going to protect
themselves tucker yeah i don't [ __ ]
think so
they tuck you you're going to send your
kids to pick up a rifle and defend those
pedophile afghani warlords
jesus tucker get with it grow up
why do we keep doing this well first of
all we have far less troops in iraq than
we have at most
times in the last to be fair i hadn't
finished watching all this i just
watched a little bit of it
online why why do we have anything we
have anything
tell me 18 years so i served in iraq
with the state department 2006.
don't ask don't tell 2007 we had a
hundred and four and there were some
problems between 2016
and now but now i'm back i'm back
there was a little four-year gap though
there were there you were allowed to in
fact ask
and you had to tell a thousand troops
at the end of 2007. we now have 2
500. so okay hey that's fine then
hey how are you doing in iraq we
checking everyone's [ __ ]
it's just like this just childish trump
walking around
you know a little less less than three
percent of why do we have any no
but why do we know it's a sincere
question we killed people in syria spent
a lot of money
focusing attention on the country of
this biden gets to go brag about
it because an american contractor
apparently was killed there apparently
by an iran-backed militia why was that
contractor there in the first place what
are we getting
out of it well there are lots of reasons
first of all and
we have troops there to fight isis ah
yes
obviously refresh my memory yes
who created isis we did who created the
power vacuum
we did and how did that happen well
because we were
we were in the middle east bombing them
and we were murdering all their leaders
correct
leaders like bashar al-assad and saddam
hussein
well know what i'm saying is leaders
like bishop
yeah so i
the fact that they could just stand here
and still say this
20 years later and everybody's like oh
that makes sense
i'm i'm i'm so angry about this who who
armed what before was called isis but
who essentially armed isis like when
they were going fighting russia
well jesus i think everyone everyone
sold them [ __ ] but mostly us and israel
but a little bit of saudi arabia in
there yeah russia
everything in that in that [ __ ] in
that jumble eye of misery
it's but it's like we create these
groups and then we're like we got to
stop these groups and you're like but we
made the group we by being there in the
first place
yeah uh and isis is still
in northern iraq and in syria and but
then how does it affect us fine even
let's we created it
whoops a daisy f i get it whoops we
created an international terrorist
organization my bad
but again isis ain't going to do [ __ ] to
us
at least not look the the effect that
isis could have on this country is not
even remotely close to the effect china
is currently having on this country
isis is an existential threat to the u.s
to our interests
it can strike at americans it's also an
existential threat to our way of life to
rule
one wait wait wait hold on how is isis
in exist and
you know i'm not putting in a good word
for isis here obviously
but existential means to threaten the
existence of something an existential
threat is something that
threatens to end you how does isis pose
an existential threat to the united
states
because isis in 2014 to 2015 set up
an islamic caliphate that had as it
stated so
five six years ago they were a threat
but even even even when they set that up
they weren't a threat but i
put by they don't even have that now it
would be like
this would be like if somebody was just
imagine if trump for four years was just
like
we got to keep an eye on those japs
their sense of [ __ ] are the biggest
existential threat to america
the japanese attacked
pearl harbor and everybody's going that
was 70 years ago
yeah but you know you know they tried to
set up an
empire 60 years ago and the germans too
we got to keep an eye on the jerk like
these are such old beefs and again going
back to my original point
beefs that we created beefs like groups
that we
created goal
to take over the middle east and europe
they had plans at one time
to try and attack uh italy they killed
many americans right well you know what
i've i've had plans before
you know i had plans to open up my own
restaurant
you know things don't always happen
though you know what i mean like
uh you know people i'm sure people have
before said you know what i'm gonna open
up an auto body shop
and maybe things didn't work out that
way in life i love that he's like they
had plans
everyone has some kind of plan sir most
of them don't happen
i'm sorry they took they took the
thousands again
i'm not i'm not flacking for isis i'm
just saying when you say they post i
mean let's use
words carefully because we're talking
about human lives in america
i love that tucker will completely shut
down people's propaganda
yeah like by by examining the words
themselves no no existential like you
do you know what that even means like
he's really challenging this guy in a
way where it's like
well yeah and now he's dude stop being
so hysterical like if you want to say
they're a threat say they're a threat
stop being hysterical because they do
that they go on tv and they go
they're the single biggest existential
threat to
america and people go i guess we'll just
bomb syria then and tucker is the only
one going okay but how though but but
like but why though
they can't even get along with each
other
you're making it seem like look like
here's do you want to talk about a
military that's [ __ ]
lock and step like chinese military
right like those [ __ ]
or shoulder to shoulder don't miss a
step and when they tell you do this you
do this
isis doesn't get along with other groups
in isis
there's it's scattered they're not gonna
do any
they're not organized enough to take
over a country
what are they gonna show up in their
toyota pickup trucks into [ __ ]
rome and just take it over i doubt it i
[ __ ] doubt it
i would literally feel better and i know
this sounds [ __ ] up
because i know we should we should
always want to be anti-war
um but to be honest like
there there are i i would feel better if
we were using all this
rhetoric against china if we were
gearing up to fight china which by the
way
would be one of those fights that you go
this is scary because we haven't had a
scary war in a long time like
the whole all middle eastern war was a
[ __ ] jerk-off
like i know people got hurt and killed
and stuff but when you think about that
compared to like
young men getting off the boats at
normandy and just getting mowed down and
like it's we we haven't had a real war
since like world war ii vietnam those
eras
so like trust me if if we were gonna go
fight china i would go
jesus man this is scary but i would
still feel better about it
than i do fighting syria and fighting
these little [ __ ] countries that have
done nothing to us
because they're at least you'd be able
to justify to me
why we're gonna fight china you could at
least tell me because of all the things
tucker just named earlier
all of those things buying up land in
the caribbean and africa taking over all
this [ __ ]
buying out our companies buying out our
politicians like i'd go okay let's fight
china
but we're we're like yo man you see
those little pricks over there and
you're like
wait syria you want to fight syria why
he's not doing anything the only thing
assad doesn't do is suck our dicks
it's the only thing he doesn't do that's
all it is he just doesn't bow and gravel
and suck our dicks and we're like we
need to clearly kill this guy
they're not an existential threat to the
united there's only one country that's
an existential threat
there's only one somebody in the chat
has a great point the syrian army has
killed more isis than we have
that's a [ __ ] thank you you're right
oh no that's true that's actually true
between them and russia yeah we're like
no we're over there fighting isis and
russia and syria like you're just
getting in our way
you're blowing our things up can you
just leave
here they're not an existential threat
to the united states one country that's
an existential threat there's only one
country that can make
my family obey and that's china
as you well know i'm sorry tucker what
with two countries but i can't every
time he says i can't
hear when people say that word it's
weird
cheney oh he's talking about jaina yeah
okay
again i know everybody in foreign policy
world was trained
like the previous generation was trained
to focus on russia the next on the
middle east
why can't we wake up and face the actual
threats
right in our face rather than
re-fighting
wars that we've lost
tucker literally good for him he finally
said what nobody was saying is
we lost the wall we lost and no way it's
like you know how many years it took for
people to finally say
hey we kind of lost vietnam right it
took a while it wasn't right away right
it was
some people were saying it but it wasn't
but it took a while for him to go
hey man we lost vietnam right we lost
that water we're like randy marsh all
beat up in the parking lot
i didn't hear any bell yes exactly
but you can't possibly be saying that we
should only focus
on one threat but we're not focusing on
it
it's again what name one thing
that [ __ ] joe biden's administration
is doing
that is focusing on china we caught
one of their spies literally [ __ ]
somebody in our intelligence agency
and the congress people said pelosi was
like it's fine
it's not a big deal we caught them we
[ __ ] caught an
intelligence agent [ __ ] and no
efforts fine
that's a problem there wasn't an
undercover isis agent [ __ ] ted cruz
and ignore all of the others isis is a
threat
can't fix baltimore
he's got a point
he has a point oh [ __ ]
if washington dc is filled with homeless
people and garbage on the streets like
we're not good at fixing stuff so like
actually we don't have the bandwidth to
fix the world and by the way
can you name one city in the united
states the democratic party i don't be
partisan or anything i'm just being
honest
this is a war cheered on by democrats
name one city united states they've
improved just one go ahead i'll wait
my my hometown cincinnati it's run by
democrats
huh that's pretty nice town i gotta say
okay i'll give you cincinnati
i can't think of any others thank you
it's not a nice town
simpson how has cincinnati improved
it's never been a nice town cincinnati's
not even the best city
in the state that's actually you're
absolutely right
that is a nice city not a very left-wing
city but we have dozens of other cities
that are actually crumbling
we have a country that's on the verge of
some kind of economic event that
probably won't be welcomed by most
people
we have a country that's getting poorer
and yet
this is like the thing that biden does
on his 36th day in office
but we don't have to give up foreign
policy in order to improve our domestic
policy
we can do both at the same time but
we're doing both
poorly yeah we're doing neither well but
neither one of them is working
so like my whole thing in life is and
this is something that would serve a lot
of people well
um if you're doing
two three four things all at the same
time and you find that you're doing all
of them poorly
then dial it back cut one thing out
maybe do three things at once or two
or maybe even focus on one thing at a
time if you try to do too many things at
once you do them poorly
and we've he's right we've been
neglecting this country for years
and we're too busy fighting for israel
and bending over and giving our [ __ ]
to china
we're america we have the resources
is iraq better is afghanistan better is
libya better is yemen better
is any country in that entire region
better
for our intervention in it well
the problems in these countries you know
pre-existed
american intervention so then why
so he's exp the by the way he he's round
about saying no it's actually worse
so if the problems pre-exist in america
why are we in there trying to fix it
it's and it didn't because we caused a
lot of it and yes there were problems
before we were there absolutely
but go look at iraq in the [ __ ] 50s
men were wearing [ __ ] suits and women
were [ __ ] driving around in
and chevy's going up the pop and now
they're all [ __ ] throwing rocks at
each other
like cavemen american intervention
didn't always
improve or make things better but also
the
but this time it will this time it's
going to be different
from interventions so i can't get over
the fact that he said cincinnati's nice
tucker has now lost all credibility with
me it's all out the window cincinnati's
terrible
everything he said up to this point i've
loved but you just
i'm done with you i'm writing tucker off
now or is the uk
france he should have he would have
actually been way more based and got way
more points for me if he went uh
cincinnati and tucker was like
what daddy jesus i don't even take
layovers in cincinnati i will fly
three extra hours to not even have to
stop there for one exactly
you know what can you uh can we just is
there a cleveland
layover could we do that instead didn't
always make it
without us being there okay then then
you're you're admitting that there's no
need for us to be there
yeah what we could all be moving toward
is improving all of the world including
why why
why why why why
why is it our job why why is it our job
like
like [ __ ] tucker said we can't even
get our own country to be nice
like and clean up like he said baltimore
is falling apart detroit's falling apart
all these cities are falling apart
and then it's like it's like imagine
if if you were just like i'm just trying
to think of this like if you were just
homeless and living in a cardboard box
but you're telling somebody else like
yeah dude i can make your house look so
dope
like just trust me here it's it's what
what track record do we have to show
people to go
look at how good we are like look at
this i would understand if the people
that run dubai
or or you know what i mean some of these
like people that have like
abu dhabi yeah like one of these like
utopian beautiful places and they're
like or
or even the japanese if we say look uh
we're gonna let the japanese run
uh all of the municipal services here in
syria because you guys are bad at it i'd
go well kelly
they have a great track record look at
them very high population
they still managed to kind of co-exist
with uh
with with uh mother earth but they still
have these beautiful cities
their [ __ ] runs really well like what
they did with covid let the japanese run
it but we're like these just
fat drunk retards that are like i'll do
it i'll fix everything and it's like no
you won't
you're going to make it worse but it's
exactly right it's
it's it's it's like instead of choosing
to hire a licensed contract that's going
to cost you more america's the one you
hire from craigslist
who's going to show up to your house
with a [ __ ] go hey do you have a
hammer
it's like being hammered drunk and going
i'll drive the bus
i've got it i've got it under control i
have you just let me let me
give it let me give him give him let me
do it
and they're like no we're not letting
you drive a giant bus thank you
uh or no actually in america's case it's
that that uh that analogy doesn't even
work
it's like me being drunk demanding the
keys from the bus but i've already
crashed the bus like six times
at this point you're like we're not
giving you the keys the seventh time
and so you know jb's got a good point
cincinnati puts chili on their spaghetti
that place is terrible oh god that's
right yep
by the way el savage says more people
died in chicago last weekend
than people because of syria yeah yeah
syrians have killed less people this
week than
local chicago natives but the middle
east does affect us
it affects our economic security it
affects our energy policy
and it affects most importantly our
security as you know
afghanistan isis came out of syria and
iraq right i can only take one over
statement of time so
i'll end with this one you say it
affects our energy policy for
generations that i lived here then
we were told we were only enmeshed in
the middle east because we were
dependent upon
their oil we needed their energy now we
don't we're energy independent
the same people who told us that are
trying to prevent us from using our own
reserves domestic reserves of energy and
again make us
uh tucker as merc stated at the
beginning of the show the president
doesn't control the gas prices he
doesn't control the price of oil you
dummy
he just signs executive orders banning
fracking and shutting down pipelines
you know what had happened he was seeing
one of those beautiful resorts in
cincinnati this weekend he's just all
loopy still yeah that's what it is man
you know i don't know if you know this
but uh
uh cincinnati a lot of people don't know
he's just like what was that planet from
star trek oh
ryzen right yeah it's it's it's paradise
you go there you sit by the pool
dependent on other nations whether it's
china
for cleaning i'm sure what tucker
china that's better energy technology or
the middle east
for petrol energy and i'm a little
confused by that why shouldn't we take a
victory lap and say
we can heat our own homes we can fuel
our own cars
we don't need you it is great that we
are
uh energy independent and
that is something that is going to
improve our security and it's something
that the middle east has taken notice of
they realize that they're that we're not
going to depend on their oil forever the
rest of the world is not going to depend
on
but their oil does it still does impact
the economic
markets why would it why would it affect
ours if we're not buying any from them
yeah why would it why would it affect
our end up
are in the about opec and all that stuff
but
but if there's one guy who's selling
weed at a rip-off price and another guy
who's selling weed at a good price
the guy selling the rip-off weed he
doesn't affect me
because i don't go to him so he could he
can sell all the ripoff wheat he wants
but if i'm not going to him it doesn't
he's he now you so now you're basically
pointing out that it's
the international markets it'll affect
the international markets
because we've become this weird
globalist like everybody's all dependent
on each other now
that's why when one market crashes they
all crash
it's terrible our system is terrible
important the flow of that oil is still
important and if economic
markets that depend on it in europe and
africa and
asia lost it or it went up so much that
uh it in
increased prices and made it harder for
them to buy american products it would
impact
our economy well you know what we could
do that would be uh i mean
just my opinion here that we wouldn't
have to worry about those prices is we
could [ __ ] tell opec and we could
tell we we could just say hey we're you
know what we don't have to listen to you
we don't feel like it
we're just gonna buy we're gonna use our
own oil we're gonna set our own prices
for american oil
sorry we're gonna buy we're gonna buy
oil from this uh
hang on what's this am i pronouncing
this right
oh al alaska yeah i know i heard you
could see russia from there we're gonna
get
from that place yeah so [ __ ] you that's
the whole reason we even got alaska
the re you think we won alaska that's a
[ __ ] sucks
but the reason we got alaska so we could
get their [ __ ] oil
we got alaska during that last purchase
of territories where they were like and
we'll throw in alaska
and you're like we don't want to even go
up there
yeah so yeah that's why even that's why
we have that state
specifically for this for this reason
the whole economy is interdependent
and middle east oil is part of that
yeah okay i still don't i'm not
convinced i was thinking about it
sure